hey everybody it is march 10th 2022 i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message we are live streaming on
rumble youtube and blaze tv do me a
favor and subscribe on rumble would you
just click the bell there and then
you'll see our videos in your feed okey
dokey
uh we are doing a reuben report locals
uh community q a today but i am going to
start with some updates on the don't say
gay bill
that's happening here in florida and
people are freaking out and everyone's
lying over it and you're not going to
believe this celebrities have chimed in
all hell is breaking loose uh before i
get to that real quick guys just
yesterday i finished day three of three
five straight uh three straight days of
five hour days of reading the audio book
for don't burn this country which comes
out on april 12th and you can get your
copy you can pre-order it right now at
daverubin.com book we've got links there
for barnes noble and for amazon and
local bookstores and all sorts of stuff
you're really gonna dig it like it was
really fun for me to read the thing and
nail the jokes and it's relevant and in
some ways it's more relevant now
than even when i wrote it and i think
you're really going to enjoy it and i'm
psyched for it to come out and next week
we will be announcing the tour i'm going
to go on tour for a couple weeks then
take a little break so i can get back in
studio uh but we've got about 10 or 15
stops on the initial leg of the tour and
then we will go from there okay before i
get to any of the questions oh in honor
of the don't say gay thing i'm i'm
wearing a pink shirt today which i've
been told is not illegal yet
in florida but could be it might be in
the bill we've got i've got my legal
people you know coming through
the the
text of the document okay uh so this
don't say gay thing it's completely
ridiculous the media has lied as they
lie about absolutely everything else so
i'm to try my best right now to calmly
explain to you as i did yesterday but
i'm trying to do it a little briefer and
very directly
calmly explain to you what actually
is in the bill so this is from
wfla.com which is one of our local
affiliates here in florida they just
laid it out you got four bullet points
or they use stars which i guess are a
little gayer five bullet points uh stars
which are a little gayer than uh bullet
points uh here are the five things that
are basically in the bill
notify parents of changes to health or
well-being in a student well of course
you would want that we went through this
yesterday so i'm going to do this very
briefly let's just real quick if
something happens to the kid if there's
the kids sick if the kid's depressed you
would want the parent to know don't
encourage withholding information with
from parents okay the state does not own
the child the parents are ultimately
responsible for the child so that would
be fine too allow parents to access
child student records why would the
school be hiding student records from
the parents like how does that make any
sense whatsoever a child is not
something that the state owns how do you
morons not realize that let parents
refuse school health care services okay
the kid is again the parent is the
custodian of the of the child and gets
to decide what health care the child is
gonna get and four get parental
permission for health screening yes if
they're gonna inject your kid with
something or they're gonna spin them in
a centrifuge or whatever they might do
with the kid the parents should probably
have to sign something just like if they
took a day trip to the arboretum the
parent would have to sign something
anyway this is what they're calling the
don't say
gay bill because within couched within
all that although the word gay is not
even in the bill
they don't want sexual orientation or
any discussion of sex or gender identity
mentioned to children in public school
from kindergarten
to third grade now really think about
that picture everyone can picture a
niece or a nephew or a child or a cousin
that's in your life that is that age
okay i told you i just went to my my
niece's seven-year-old birthday party uh
this sunday imagine saying to a first
grader uh talk to me about your feelings
about sexual identity or your gender or
any of that stuff it's absolutely
psychotic we all know it is but the
media just lies and lies about
everything and then hollywood
celebrities check in
and one of the strange things about
growing up is that you ultimately find
out that all of your childhood heroes
are complete bananas lunatics here's
what luke skywalker
had to say about the
don't say gay bill
uh gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay i don't think i have to read the
whole thing and even put in a rainbow to
really drive
home the point now of course you can
say gay but
connor who sits behind the computer over
there he said dave i've got an idea and
he put together two memes using star
wars clips now that one of course is
from the mandalorian and now we know now
we know thank you connor we now know
what mandalorian was all about it was
actually about mando trying to hide
grogu from luke skywalker because luke
wanted to chop grogu's genitals off
the it changes the entire thing okay so
at the end there when luke when you
watch the last episode and luke is
saving grogu he's taking him for gender
reassignment surgery okay you see that
now we got one more for you a little
more old school
old school star wars for you luke you
should read the bill
that's some good work there connor
mine work fine work anyway okay so i get
it the celebrities are all idiots okay
so be it well then we found this guy
this is state senator florida state
senator gary farmer he's a state senator
from broward county he said florida's
don't say gay bill is a cruel attempt to
erase
lgbtq plus children and families in our
communities i will not back down from
fighting to protect children and
families in our state from this
unwarranted hate okay so everything he
said there is a lie the word gay is not
in it it has nothing to do with erasing
anybody this is about parents knowing
what their kids are being taught and
then he took a piece of black tape and
then he wrote gay over it now i used to
live in west hollywood there were clubs
that you had to pay to pay to go in to
do something like that okay uh now can
you put it up one more time because he
puts this thing up he's a state senator
he's very he just loves the gays oh my
god he wants everybody to know about it
he got 209
likes on that pandering ridiculous tweet
so then i thought
i'm a new floridian maybe i could invite
him on the show so i retweeted it i said
hey senator as a new floridian i'd love
to have you on my show to discuss why
you want a state employee to talk to a
first grader about sexuality and then be
able to hide that conversation from the
child's parents let me know when you're
available that got 22 000
likes
now i'm not making this oh i'm being
told it's 25 000 likes now incredible
thank you for the live update um so look
farmer you've seen it you've seen it
dude and uh here look i haven't brought
i got a little tape for you if you if
you come to the studio and your tape
falls off we'll give you one of these
god it's so idiotic
but more more and more from these these
crazy people so the mainstream media is
running with this thing and and it's
like we have to debunk the nonsense just
as fast as they put it out but it's
almost impossible to keep up with them
so cnn of course is all over this you
know desantis hates gay people florida
doesn't like bisexuals whatever uh so
here's a florida democrat chevron jones
warning that this could cause uh
apparently first graders to start
committing suicide take a look
are you worried that you know a young
person
who
you know realizes they're gay that they
won't be able to be themselves i mean
what is or they will be discriminated
against that that could be endorsed
essentially by this bill what is the
concern about the environment this would
create
absolutely it's going to create an
environment where it's going to continue
to keep children
more closeted it's going to put more of
a censor on teachers where teachers are
as a former teacher teachers are the
first responders uh to uh a lot of
problems that uh children come to speak
to someone about uh so is is not going
to be beneficial to uh to the teacher
nor to uh to the student
you know i have this uh
this
money jar here and what i've been doing
with this is every time i gratuitously
mention california i put some more money
in the jar and at the end of the year
i'm going to be giving this money for
somebody that wants to escape california
and move to florida i think i have to
start a second jar i know it's a lot of
cash for me uh but i have to start a
second jar where i will pay people to
actually leave florida because first off
briana keeler there i think that's her
name the cnn i mean her question is so
her question has nothing to do with
reality it has nothing to do with what's
in the bill okay fine um but what is he
talking about closeted first graders
that have to talk to their teachers like
it's kids don't think about this [ __ ]
what is wrong with you people and if you
really want to see what's wrong with
them here's some other florida state
senators they're all democrats in the in
the capitol talking about this scary
bill
do we really think that teachers are
engineering students to become gay you
can't teach gay
because we oppose the bill we're
pedophiles school boards are not in fact
conspiring to turn children gay free
state of florida
not if you're gay
i asked a couple members from the other
side of the aisle
are you really okay with this bill
and a couple of you said
no
but i have to be
no you don't
no you don't
no you really don't
the only same thing there that i heard
was you can't teach gay because if you
could i mean think about it donald trump
went out to thousands uh of people at
these rallies in front of thousands of
people came out to ymca and dance did
they all turn gay no so you can't teach
gay okay finally and then this was this
was very upsetting for me this morning
because you know i make light of a lot
of this stuff but sometimes something
happens in your own personal life and
you go wow maybe we do have a bigger
problem on our hand uh this morning as i
was preparing for the show i had my
coffee i was
walking to the uh to the kitchen there
to get some extra creamer and i just i
was thinking about the show and i just i
just sort of whispered almost mumbled
the word gay to myself but it did come
out
like that and watch what happened
clyde freaked out okay so clyde is
possibly one of desantis's paid goons
okay where if you say gay they've
they've done something to the animals
well that where
where they will attack you
lord all right let's do uh some
questions from the reuben report locals
community patrick where do you find your
inspiration
to write your books you know
it's sort of it's sort of what you see
here every day like you guys kind of
know at this point what drives me and
what i'm thinking about and what i'm
frustrated about and what i find funny
and all that stuff the the first book
don't burn this book was very easy to
write in a certain way even though it
was my first book because it was just
sort of like going through everything
that i had been talking about really
like like here was why i left the left
here's what that sit down with larry
elder was like here was what touring
with jordan was like here was you know
first getting hate from the lefties and
like the story that you kind of all knew
and then and then just laying out what
what my beliefs are this book was a
little more difficult because it was a
little wonkier and it's a little more
like well how do we beat this thing how
do we fight back against this thing how
do we not just complain how do we build
it's a different book but i promise you
it's
it's fun and it's real and it's
heartfelt at the end i was like wow i
really did write something kind of kind
of heartfelt here too and i really do
think you're going to dig it but where
does the inspiration come i mean it's
just
if you're alive man there's so much
going on right now and as i say it's
like it can be depressing it really can
especially if you're just doing the news
thing over and over and one of the
things i lay out in the book is why you
should not do the news thing over and
over and if you're watching this and
it's upsetting you all day long you
should stop watching this i really mean
that i try to do it in a way that it
hopefully won't be upsetting you but can
enlighten you a little bit and make you
laugh a little bit and that's that um
but if you're doing the politics thing
all day long it's and especially if
politics is just your worldview it's
going to depress you so i tried to write
the book in a way that it's yeah it's
some politics but it's more culture and
it's it's more lifestyle and yeah you
will dig it uh bernardo says are you
still planning to build that
state-of-the-art studio for locals down
here yes that's right so locals so we
had
we had really fantastic offices that we
had put an offer in in uh in wynwood
which is sort of like a trendy area here
in miami a lot of young people like very
cool studio space it actually didn't
work out but uh you guys are going today
right uh the team is going today we
found some new offices uh we're going to
check out see what kind of studio we can
build and uh yes so we're going to have
studios locals will have studios here in
miami that any locals creator that's in
town can use for whatever they want to
which is going to it's basically going
to be open 24 hours a day and we're
going to have a crew and you can just
come if you're a creator and use our
studios and then rumble's building
incredible studios right on the water in
sarasota so that's on the on the west
coast of florida so we're going to have
an east coast hub a west coast hub and
uh i don't know if you know this but
florida is the future uh darlena says
will cuomo make a comeback you know it's
funny uh i don't know which cuomo you're
talking about because both of them are
kind of up the creek at the moment of
course there was former new york
governor
andrew cuomo although i suspect you're
talking about his brother chris cuomo
from cnn but
governor andrew cuomo had to step down
because of the sexual assault
allegations and it was very unclear
really what happened there
i do think he might try to make a
comeback and the funny thing is now that
they got kathy seaward you know kathy
hoechel i call her kathy c word who has
been exposed to be sort of just the
worst sort of hysterical she's still got
the kids in masks right now she's just
evil and vile and nobody voted for her
now that they've got her i think a lot
of people in new york are going man we
sure do wish we had the guy who killed
all the old people who was sexually
harassing a couple people because this
[ __ ] is nuts so
you know
so there goes the all right we're
demonetized okay sorry guys um
but that's the truth like the thing is
that what happens with these lefties is
they always go worse they they never
look in the mirror they never turn
around so i think there will be some
sort of opening for uh for andrew cuomo
to come back probably uh as for chris
cuomo
yeah of course he'll be back because he
did first off he didn't break a law like
they fired him for whatever internal
stuff they fired him for um but he can
obviously come back and whether he goes
independent or goes to another network
like that's just how it is and america
loves to come back and uh you know what
i'll make even i'll even make a
commitment if he comes back and he wants
to do this show i will interview him
glad i will gladly interview him happy
to talk to him
kerry says where what do you find more
fulfilling writing a book or touring for
the book after release it seems
interacting with fans would offer a more
noteworthy reaction than critic reviews
um
there's something about writing a book
and finishing it like that last moment
that you finish it that is extremely
rewarding because
it's kind of fun when you're in the flow
and it's just like coming out of you and
then there's a lot of times that it's
not or you have to move things i really
hate the editing process my editor my
editor helen from penguin is amazing and
she was really great and and spent days
twice visited for you know four days and
we'd just like hunker down and tr you
know
rip everything up and trash it and
rewrite and blah blah blah
but i don't like the technical stuff i'm
not i'm not very good at the uh the
computer there so i don't like like
having to move things from a google doc
into a word doc and then they got a pdf
it and copy and paste and like i don't
like all the technical stuff of it i
like the idea stuff um but in terms of
touring you know when don't burn this
book came out it was at the height of
the pandemic and we canceled the entire
tour i had i had like a 60-stop tour we
were going to go to like seven or eight
countries um and i was so excited to do
that and then basically my book tour was
this it was it was me staring into a
camera talking to people
so i really really missed it so i am i'm
seriously psyched uh so as i said we're
gonna do like just a two three week tour
just to start uh i believe the first
stop is if i'm not mistaken it's april
11th in new york that's all i can say at
the moment and i wasn't going to tour in
any place or city that had mask mandates
or vaccine passports or any of that but
apparently we found a venue in new york
that is allowing it and things are
opening up but god only knows what'll
happen in the next month
um but yeah i love being out there with
people like i just love meeting people i
love as i said i love saying hi to
people you know people when they hug me
i don't like the extended hug i like
just a short quick hug but i just like
being out there with people and
especially after these last two years of
of hiding from each other and being
locked away and everything else so
they're both rewarding but but kind of
there's like a completion
of writing a book that that's really
good but then the sort of immediate
reaction of seeing people making people
laugh and you know when i do the book
tour i've been thinking about sort of
what do i want i can do whatever i want
to do and you know i toured with jordan
peterson and it was like he was doing
the 12 rules for life
tour but sometimes he would do three
weeks of shows in a row where he didn't
ever even discuss the book it was just
whatever was on his mind so i'll
probably do something like that the
shows will be different every night i
promise you that it'll just be kind of
what's in my head and playing with the
crowd and i'll give away some stuff and
yeah i think they'll dig it uh al says
why doesn't the biden administration
sign an executive order to give 17
trillion to americans to replace all 289
million vehicles on the road with
tesla's al i see what you did there very
clever um
well first off um he would not do it
with tesla because he does not like
tesla and elon musk does not like him
you know he wants to back some of the
big boys gm etc who are moving into
electric vehicles he really wants to
keep that machine nice and greased um he
does not love tesla because elon musk's
elon musk is a true innovator i think
he's a lot of libertarian beliefs as i
say he gets
benefits and he gets some tax breaks and
subsidies from the government but he's
not a big government guy
but more broadly to your point it's like
that could be coming next they since
they just make up the numbers right like
since they just make up all of the
numbers you know now i saw mitch
mcconnell yesterday we have to give 14
billion
to ukraine and it's like
we have no money do you guys know that
america has no money we have a
tremendous amount of debt so if you
personally had no money and a tremendous
amount of debt you wouldn't look to be
lending other people money and it just
gets us further and further into debt
with china so china's just looking
around going man this is pretty sweet
all of these broke countries just keep
borrowing money and we're just going to
own everybody
so
yeah oh and you know elon musk is also
kind of anti-union so there's a lot of
things that don't quite fit in what joe
biden would do there
in terms of tesla um but
since we just make up the numbers i
could it's not out of the realm of
possibility that could you like would it
surprise you it's a month from now and
joe biden just gets up there and he's
like you know this rush of things well
i'm doing joe biden as if he could speak
clearly but in essence if he said
something like you know uh this russia
thing's a mess and uh we just came up
with 17 trillion and you got to return
your cars and we're going to give you
all electric vehicles or something like
that like it wouldn't surprise me
because they're trying to destroy the
old world it's just very obvious uh
anne-marie says you mentioned yesterday
david was not originally sold on the
move to florida
what is your opinion now is he as happy
with the move as you or is he still
adjusting so what i was talking about
was
you know the last couple of months
in flor in california
um you know when the recall was
happening especially i was pumped i was
juiced i was out on the road with larry
elder i was meeting people it felt like
being on tour again there was such
excitement it was good to see people
again because california had been so
locked down and all that stuff so i was
really really psyched and that that got
us into sort of september period and
then the recall failed miserably and we
can
talk about all the reasons for that
another time um and then three days
after
the recall we got audited by the state
and they went through three years of my
amazon purchases as i said it's a lot of
hairspray um and then then i was
basically done
you know our life though in terms of
just like our day-to-day life and i
think we all have this we all have sort
of a private life and even if you're not
a public person you have a public life
meaning you have your life with your
family
like in your home and then you have sort
of who you are outside of your home and
all the things that go on there our life
in our home was was very good like we
love to cook we love to host we love to
have family and friends over and we were
having illegal parties and like we were
just living our life and doing our thing
so i would always say like what what
happened in our
in our house in the in the four walls
of our fence like that was all good but
going out just became miserable everyone
was miserable everywhere these people
never wanted to stop taking off masks
they they looked sort of just dead in
the eye everywhere and and then i would
go to stores sometimes we'd go just to
like you know pick up some food and we'd
go and i would always try not to wear
the mask at first and david was fine
with that i always say like look if
someone says something to me i'll put it
on and then you know we'd go to the
store and a security guard would yell at
me and then i'd put it on but it would
be beneath my nose and then a random
woman would yell at me and then i'd put
it up for a second and then i tried and
then finally one time david looked at me
he's like you know you don't have to
come shopping with me if you don't want
and he did it like sort of lovingly like
you don't have to do this if you don't
want but it's like you should be able to
go shopping and not feel like an outcast
in the city that you were in so anyway
all of that being said he was not as
crazed of like let's get the f out of
here as a lot of interesting things
happening that i'll have some more
updates on soon um but like
it's probably not quite the level like
i'm just like i wake up every morning
i'm like i can't this is as good as it
gets i got iguanas i got lizards i got
peacocks you know you you can say gay
and nobody gets you you know all right
amy says do you think that the insanely
high gas prices are the final nail in
the democrat coffin for the 2022 midterm
elections or are the people who hated
trump so much still overwhelmed with the
joy of no mean tweets man i'll tell you
i don't think there's a cert there's a
certain
percentage of people
that are so long gone that the economy
could crash unemployment could be crazy
inflation could be nuts gas prices never
seen before and they would still rather
all that than just the idea of orange
man they'd still the democrat thing has
become a cult it's become a cult because
it's so enforced by all of our cultural
norms whether it's you turning on
netflix and getting propaganda or
whether you're turning on cnn and
they're screaming about how florida
wants to take out gay people i mean it's
so the whole machine has just
brainwashed so many people that i would
say this i mean you just don't know what
tricks
you just don't know what tricks they are
going to do before the midterms and also
and i want to be very clear about this i
do not want to be in a war in effect we
are in a war right now even though this
is a war between russia and ukraine in a
you know we're basically in a war
because everything is sort of worldwide
now we're talking about sending arms
there's people that want to do no-fly
zones all of these things
without getting lost in like the minutia
of that when you're in a war it's
usually good for the incumbent because
the feeling is oh we can't change things
in the middle of a war so it's like
could you would you put it past biden
and the democrats to actually escalate
the war so that people feel that they
have to keep them in power i would put
absolutely nothing past them so there's
a certain amount of people that no
matter how
economically hurt they are no matter
whether we have a war
or god knows what like god only knows
what these people are up to and what
they could do
so i think we have to be very concerned
that uh you know everyone's saying red
wave red wave and it's like we all got a
freaking vote you gotta vote and keep
the pressure on you just gotta do it you
gotta do it
w says i'm wondering how big the
conservative gay movement is can it even
be called that and how does the
community feel about the way mainstream
media portrays the gay community you
know i don't like the phrase
like gay community it doesn't it doesn't
really mean that much to me like i have
some gay friends and i have some
straight friends and i don't really
think about it any other which way
um
but but your question like like if we're
to think of people in some ways like we
do group off people in some ways right
so
look to me one of the reasons that i've
been pushing so hard against the this
don't say gay nonsense is because if
you're just the average gay person which
i think most gay people are you're just
like the average person who just wants
to live your life peacefully and
hopefully find someone that you want to
live that life with and everything else
you should be railing against all of
this woke lunacy more than the average
person because they're they're making
you look like a radical lunatic right so
i have nothing to do with those people i
have nothing to do with those people and
they're the worst sort of pandering
like i don't think that guy cares about
farmer whatever his name was state
senator farmer i don't think he really
cares about gay people like and i don't
think he cares that he obviously doesn't
care about truth like i know he doesn't
care about truth but i don't think he
really cares about gay people either if
you cared about gay people all you would
want are equal rights and then get out
of the way that that's the beauty of
america that's the promise of america so
i think for the average gay conservative
i mean think about it this way this
there's there is this meme out there
sort of like you can't be gay and
conservative and it's like what is your
sexuality have to do with your feeling
about taxes what does your sexuality
have to do with your feeling about
foreign policy what does your sexuality
have to do with your feelings about free
speech or the size of government or or
virtually anything or environmental
policy i mean basically anything other
than
you would like to be in a legal
relationship with someone that you love
pretty much nothing but they this is
just another massive trick that they
have pulled right in front of all of us
so i tend to think that
the same gay people that are out there
and and most of them are eventually
they're the ones that are going to have
to fight against this woke stuff because
because almost everything is ruined by
wokesters who again do they mean well
well the road to hell is paid for good
intentions and all that stuff
uh cooper says dave and he plans to
record a comedy special preferably
apolitical you know i've been thinking
about it for a long time we were
thinking about doing like an hour-long
special that i would probably just
release here or or on locals let me get
through the tour kind of see how i'm
feeling about everything and it would be
it would look it would be somewhat
political obviously
but it wouldn't be like bludgeon
bludgeoning you with politics
relentlessly um but there's a lot
cooking so i got to get through the tour
before i can really think about that uh
monique says coming into this midterm
election what would be the one question
you would ask a potential candidate
running at the state level and the
federal level to discern whether this
person will be a ron desantis or a
spineless neocon business as usual
conservative
good question it's a good question you
know i heard i mentioned on the show a
couple days ago i went to an event in
bal harbor which is a little
neighborhood here in miami uh last week
i went to an event and i heard ron de
santa speak it was probably about 30 or
so people and take some questions
and what he kept talking about was that
he doesn't do things by polls he was
elected to lead and he does what he
thinks is right and if he makes mistakes
along the way then he reevaluates but he
really is just going by his
internal compass of what he thinks is
right and his and his belief in this
country and the laws and all of those
things and and he really really loves
florida it's just very obvious that he
does
um i think the question that you'd want
to ask people at this point
is
like do you believe in yourself enough
that you would be willing to stand up
the way that you should when the machine
comes for you i mean one of desantis's
best traits right now is that when they
lie about him and they lie about him
about literally everything right don't
say gay covet ever he's killing grandma
he's coming for gay people i mean they
lie
about him
related to the worst things i mean they
say the worst possible things and yet
this is an incredibly flourishing
wonderful magical state uh you've got
disney coming after him now because the
ceo of disney just yesterday said that
he wants to have a sit down with ron
desantis over the don't say gay bill and
then ron desantis did something really
freaking fantastic
maybe we'll even cover it tomorrow he
released a statement where he said that
uh he stands by the bill and in essence
he's like you know parents also send
their children to disney and i believe
i'm doing the thing that's right for the
parents so it was sort of like a threat
back it was like so disney you better
watch out because it's parents that
bring their kids to disney world so he
punches back so the question would
really be like are you really willing to
do it are you willing to stand up to the
machine and it's like we can all say
that we would
we can all say that we would do the
unpopular thing and it's like how often
you watching this right now like how
often do you in your life stand up for
what you really believe in how often do
you actually say anything that's
unpopular ago or go against the grain
and i would point that at myself too
like i do the best that i can but could
we all do better actually
if don't burn these countries coming out
on april 12th and there's a whole
chapter devoted to this like we must do
it we must do it because i really think
it's like even though we're fighting
this big monster
maybe what defeats it is just enough of
us just enough of us i'm just not going
to play anymore i'm not going to play
this [ __ ] game
i'm not going to acquiesce anymore i'm
not going to give it any more oxygen i'm
just going to live my life the best that
i can and i'm just going to do better
and build better things and make better
art and and
and not be part of this monster but for
a politician that's got to be part of
the monster um you got to be willing to
stand up and it's very easy to say
you'll do it but you actually got to do
it
renee says i have a friend whose name is
gay
would she have to change her name if she
visits florida this sounds very serious
we're going to have to look into that
can we get the uh the reuben report
private investigator to find out about
that yes i mean people named gay here in
florida
uh could be under threat and we can't
have that so we're gonna find out about
that god it's all so
nuts
margot says any thoughts on the very
recent information from tucker carlson
on the bio labs in ukraine so i just saw
a little clip about this this morning
actually i guess tucker's been covering
this the last two nights apparently
there are some bio labs that possibly
were funded by the united states in
ukraine that could be under threat
like this has covid ii written all over
it like you see what happened russia
bombed the biolabs the biolabs blew up
and we have a new pandemic get your 18
shots people
um i don't know enough about it to
comment on it specifically but we will
look more into it and we'll we'll cover
it next week ian says when your book
tour rolls around will you make a stop
in sharack chicago or the surrounding
south suburbs or towns such as joliet
illinois i don't think on this first leg
we got
chicago i don't think so but i'm not
allowed to say what we have yet i'm
going to announce the tour on monday oh
we do chicago's in i'm not sure i was
supposed to say that chicago i will be
there chicago uh all right sounds good
there we go
not gonna say the date but i will be in
chicago in april 100 percent and i
already said new york that's all i can
say a lot of stops in florida okay stop
saying stuff dave okay ashlynn says if
trump was still in office and was
supportive of the vaccine what would the
left's position be would they also be
supporting the vaccine or be wary of it
because trump is supporting it
this is such a key to like everything
that's going on right now if you really
think about now now trump did operation
war warp speed trump subsequently even
in the last few months is still sort of
pro vaccine okay that's fine you can
agree with him or not that's just fine
and again you should make the decision
that's best for you
um
but so many people made their decisions
based on either what trump thought or
what trump didn't think meaning if trump
had been president for the this last
year and trump had been for mandates
you must be mandated otherwise you will
get fired from your job otherwise we are
going to fire nurses we are going to
fire teachers we're going to fire
federal workers if trump had done all
that
all of the people that were cheering it
on as biden did it would have been
saying this is hitler this is evil this
is authoritarian and everything else you
know that to be true
right like it's just so obvious
so many people made their life
their compass became based on trump and
that's a crazy thing if donald trump had
been for mandates forcing people
to do things against their will and then
having people fired and all of those
things one day we're calling frontline
workers the greatest series of heroes of
all time the next day we're firing them
if trump had been doing that well first
off we'd be an impeachment 17 but the
exact same people who were for it under
biden would be against it and we just
know that so i would like to think that
i've remained pretty freaking consistent
throughout this stuff and i just didn't
want government coercion either way and
that choice should be left up to you um
but it will be interesting you know this
is a little bit of the catch-22 if
trump's to run again right because if
trump runs again on one hand we have a
very very damaged mentally and
physically and politically joe biden
right so he's sort of weak and then the
the woman behind him is just absolutely
terrible so there's not a huge amount of
support for these people the far lefties
don't like them enough they're like what
is their base anymore
everything is pretty freaking terrible
at the moment
so on one hand it's like you should just
find a republican that you could put in
there that could just do it that could
just do it now i've said it before i'll
say it again i don't want it to be
desantis because i want him to stay here
in florida and let's keep modeling this
state the right way but could you find
someone else that's like pretty good
that's pretty good that's willing to
stand up to the machine that will just
be statesmanlike and decent and have
some basic understanding of the
constitution and how the whole thing's
supposed to run could you find that
person and then run it against that very
damaged joe biden i hope so i don't know
who that is but but
because otherwise if trump runs you fire
up their base
right so you get a lot of people the
trump people are now very excited and
that's all good and you guys know i
voted for him and i would most likely
vote for him again
so this is not a condemnation of trump
in that regard but what you do by having
him run is the base of the left and the
entire freaking machine the crazy
machine starts ramping it up again
ramping up all the craziness and
hitler's two he's coming back
and then and then it's like man did you
just instigate 10 million people that
weren't going to vote to suddenly vote
you know 10 million people who would
have stayed home if say rick
rick scott or
you know anybody i was gonna say tim
scott but rick scott would be fine too
anyone named scott was gonna run as a
republican that all these people would
stay home but now it's trump so they're
freaking out and then suddenly they get
this many more votes these are all the
internal things that i think the
republicans have to be talking about and
and trump is probably thinking about to
some degree
uh all right last question of the day
landon i like that name uh says once
desantis can't run anymore who would you
want to run for governor um i think
there's some interesting options here
well first off
if he if he runs again and wins again
okay he's had his two terms he's out
then maybe he runs for president we'll
see but there would be a little gap in
time probably a two-year window
you know because the the elections don't
match up exactly um who would i want i
mean look mayor suarez down here in
miami is awesome i think the guy is
absolutely
awesome he is fully welcoming of the new
people that are coming here to
experience freedom he is he's a
basically a small government guy he's
figuring out all sorts of ways for these
tech companies to come here and flourish
the economy here is flourishing um he's
just a good dude like he's just i've met
him a couple times i've had him on the
show if you haven't seen that episode
he's just a good guy so
uh i think he would be a good one i you
know um i think maybe kaylee mcinerney
is she here she's in new york now i
guess but she's originally from here if
i'm not mistaken like kaylee you want to
run like that would be pretty good you
were pretty damn good spokesperson at
the white house like that would be
something i think that there would be
like a nice crop of republicans i'm
actually i'm actually not too worried
about florida you know i'm worried even
though this is where i live and i want
it to stay as strong as possible i'm
worried about the future of the country
obviously but i think florida the model
is so right and and look look at the
democrats that
we showed you before those people at the
house up in tallahassee screaming
gay gay gay and
like this guy like this is the guy that
we all have to worry about
so i think everything's going to be okay
down here in florida
i really do
guys we're bringing back the panel
tomorrow the panel bonanza will be back
on friday uh and what else can i tell
you uh part two of my interview with uh
former u.s ambassador to the u.n nikki
haley is up on youtube in rumble right
now to pull things up on locals you can
pre-order don't burn this country at
daverubin.com
book look at that cover huh
we designed it ourselves we we mostly
did the design there and then we had
their graphic people come in uh but that
was mostly us pretty not bad i'd say
pretty good surviving and thriving in
our woke dystopia lordy did i nail it
with the subtitle because we are in
awoke dystopia uh the round table guests
tomorrow are ian hayworth uh from the
daily wire he is a first-time reuben
report guest sarah gonzalez from the
blaze and kyle becker formerly of fox
who's now an independent journalist who
actually is one of the people on uh we
did confirm kyle right
we didn't confirm kyle he better say yes
i requested him on the show we'll see
what happens
all right people get out there say gay
don't say gay nobody cares
do what you got to do see you tomorrow